how's the gum bros my name is beautify
welcome back do not spit hah - punching
doors but back at all he talks in this
game right rah rah rah rah got dark and
jumps hurt her
anyway in the last episode we killed
father I don't know what his faces
I mean name is father derp face I would
call him that just my opinion but we
need to shave the go yeah when you save
the girl with big titties Ikey I found
the kid to East Wing and I find a wooden
stake now let's not kill the dog out it
dog I love this I want to see how this
dog is business it was my awesome dog
father I will shave your life don't
worry oh it's not working okay let's do
a mother Evan save lie here and then use
the key yes progress oh I like it
the thing is I have for health what is
this oh it's a wooden stick alright I
need the window sticks for the vampires
alright come here when buyers chop chop
chop chop chop
I'm gonna friggin I don't like it
battles
okay go ahead sword fighting chop chop
chop
oh no he got out I have for help what do
you want of it how do I have such a
little help I should have changed
difficulty to normal
God dang it I feel like I'm screwed
alright maybe okay I got this
pick up the wooden sticks all right I
don't like this very much
let's save again and that's stablish
mother-effer all right Oh Lacey come on
babe ah come on
hi description okay - fall back 100
right in the bow lady I hid my phone
behind that's not fair alright I got a
new tactic night and you tag it don't
worry bro I got this for health no
problem
oh not a problem at all
wish I had help Exile wasn't the health
bags in the actually no we are gonna
take a step back it's alright now we can
say hi to father derp face stop butter
you think you kill me [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate you if I ever see you
again I'm gonna [ __ ] you swear a lot
to being a priest that's not cool
alright let's see if we can find some
health packs harping around I mean
scatter around here
barrel barrel saw me kill father it
should be here somewhere I'm walking so
slow come on
period everywhere serious it up here her
it's gonna be health bag or something
maybe you can recharge your health here
outside or something what is this that's
a lot of a lot of I'm going outside I
can I can do that let's get my health
packs or something wooden stakes and
please come on come on come on give me
something
no no give me health know that of this
drunk no I give me the wooden stakes all
right fine I don't need anything of God
no okay I got this it's no problem
what about these rooms
anything useful oh yes health pack I
knew it
I'm a genius all right let's progress
[ __ ] all right this [ __ ]
vampire is gonna I don't even know what
it is
save okay let's I just want to see the
girl with a big kid all right come on
bro
hell out bells oh okay
come a bra
I have one half thanks see you mutt ah
god dammit did not work as intended
[ __ ] bells hey hey yeah that I can know
I actually know you deserting you don't
just share my sword you deserve my
punches but but but [ __ ] girls
I [ __ ] hate all of you
alright no more this is a chef's no it's
a bell heard all right fine I'll take
this I don't like this very much alright
never would have a wooden stake come at
me bro not afraid of anyone them I was
just kidding I'm scared he's [ __ ]
gone me as I don't need to save here for
shizzle my sensitive I have finger
toffee you like my strafing skills oh ha
ha ha ha I got your flintlock gun
alright give me that give me that
yeah oh I have a gun now give me a
health pack please oh no I don't have a
health bag
yes alright what is this gun powder than
bullets
yay yay I like that let's save a lot of
saving oh now I wasting ammo
alright whatever it's fine this one shot
right then I come from here yeah then
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right ah
don't respond oh now he responds if you
leave all right fine we'd save luckily
enough this reminds me of Ionia lock
side thigh I'm not very good at this
game I am average at least I'm slightly
above average I would shave addley all
right oh no oh no oh no no no should
open over to over and over know which
snow would know we snow it oh he just Oh
No ah
got that right I hate yeah yeah you
can't even jump oh that's what I did
people like Yelp by why would you scare
me like that
I had nothing to desire it nothing
I haven't found nation I can't even jump
what fire where where where
alright yeah bad as a dog okay okay
here's a dog time Fred tactic tactic
okay let me think I have I have I have a
crucifix okay no let me use this gun
alright let's shoot the point Greg
personhood dog your dad
dog your oh no oh no I have to read oh
okay
alright it's cool your dad yes okay
let's chop let's save yeah all right
and the dog what are you where's the dog
ah I dragged me you died I was hiding
babe
that's fine I say don't worry
Jesus Christ it sounds in this game is
freaking terrifying even though I know
the graphics suck because it sucks I
don't like this game you should play
battlefield 3 and as you loved better
graphics
alright let's kill this [ __ ] dog I
think you're hiding Yahoo I have a
medium health pack [ __ ]
alright the flintlock gum I don't even
need it let's save here alright
I've seen these boxes but Harper derp
derp better be something where's the
girl with the big tits seriously thought
it's not funny anymore this gun is
awesome one shot kill [ __ ] it's
like the Golden Gun and double-oh-seven
Golden Gun Goldeneye I mean [ __ ] what am
I talking about
alright what are you I know you're here
I know you're here oh there's just
sweets a venetian machine gun hahaha I
like a hotter girl I like that a lot
alright oh no what did they do to you
what did it tell you I'm just gonna stab
you a couple of times make sure your dad
good pretty sure is dead but I don't
trust them cuz there's a barrel here a
lot of barrels here alright I found the
wooden stake gun the powder and bullets
good alright
what's in here what is this place I
don't trust any of it
I think I need to go here pal what are
you doing ah tiny barrel all right but
this is scoop that is a dog hi doggie
come back quick come on no it's can't
come come here
you did that oh no what did they do to
you you're so ugly and dead and now
father I will sing suka plea deal under
the party one vampires are creatures of
the night and during the day they enter
a comma like sleep
vampires usually passes some passes
possess some unusual supernatural
attributes man spiders avoid garlic
sunlight sacred symbols such as crucifix
and holy water and they may need to
sleep and their net on the native soil
in soils they may be native soils either
come they may be killed by thrusting a
snake
I mean stake through their heads all
right that's the only way to kill
vampires I don't trust you I don't trust
you even though I like their did how
they look I kind of cool all right focus
pity focus I don't trust any one of you
oh [ __ ] the scared penis out of me all
right I don't have a lot of time today
Rose I'm sorry I don't know how long I
record it but I'm gonna in here I hope
you enjoyed leave a like and favorite if
you did subscribe to come on bro today
and I'll see you tomorrow here comes a
rough week god damn this [ __ ] girl
dude Oh mother of penis [ __ ]
perfect huh they have a gangbang here
too